with an AI system like a larger language
model you can just shoot the it's
more like drinking a beer versus like uh
doing homework yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's already happening what do you think
about that becoming the new family to
where
you know you said you're not married you
don't have kids could you see a future
for yourself whether you have a
relationship with AI and that is your
family and that's the main that's the
primary like even a romantic
relationship yeah
I could see it that one worries me
I like to keep it at friends right
I think I'm not ready to commit to the
match
um it's I wonder how much that now that
takes us back to the Amazon in nature
how much we still need the human touch
yeah and whatever magic there is between
two humans which takes the leap into the
romantic
versus just the intimacy of a good
friendship I don't know
so
correct if I'm wrong you you see AI is
having a deep and meaningful friendship
yes
and hopefully it will be a friend that
will help you evolve and be able to love
even more and be loved and you can take
that into humanity and find another Homo
Sapien yes to go
yes
and thank you AI my great friend for
opening me up to this beauty that I have
myself I can see in you
my fellow
human and let's come together and
biologically create family if we want to
and let's all remain friends with my
friend and make your own friends with my
friend's friends on AI and let's have
these great
neighbor it's a good friend that great
friend that's a neighbor okay mentor and
friend just like uh now there's AI
systems that play chess far far far
better than humans and we humans still
play chess with each other
or the chess is still a game that's fun
for us humans right and then we use AI
systems to get better just to learn to
train to discover new ideas but
ultimately return to the chess board
between two humans
uh but of course this world is full of
dangerous people and so those same AI
systems can be used to um
to harm to create false narratives to uh
do social engineering and manipulate the
masses
in terms of what they believe and all
that kind of stuff that's scary yeah